[Music]
when the Hoover Dam was completed in
1936 it created a huge source of
hydroelectric power and zapped a sleepy
desert town to life Las Vegas Nevada
with the power supply from the dam Las
Vegas soon exploded with vibrant
displays the source of these dazzling
lights was electrified neon gas there
are two tricky obstacles to making
lighted signs out of this naturally
clear odorless gas capturing it and
making it glow French inventor George
Claude came up with techniques to do
both in 1902 he developed a way of
liquefying and separating specific gases
from the air producing neon on an
industrial scale for the first time by
1910 he had come up with a way to trap
the gas in a glass tube with a special
electrode at either end and neon
lighting was born in workshops like
clothes artisans known as tube Bender's
made neon signs by hand the tube benders
heated small sections of a long hollow
glass tube and quickly bent them into
shape after the glass cooled they
attached electrodes to each end and
removed the air with a vacuum pump then
they passed a high voltage current
through the tube to remove any
impurities on the inside of the glass
finally they pumped the neon gas in and
sealed off the electrodes when a neon
sign is turned on the electric current
causes some of the neon atoms electrons
to accelerate and break free of their
orbits leaving behind positively charged
ions as these free electrons rush from
one electrode to the other they collide
with more neon atoms causing them to
ionize as well
when these excited electrons fall back
to their normal energy levels their
excess energy is carried away by photons
or particles of light all this happens
in an instant and the glow from the
photons is what we see when we switch on
a neon sign though it's common to call
any gas field sign a neon sign there are
actually five different gases used in
production each gas emits photons of a
different wavelength and electrified
which corresponds to different colors of
light
neon gives off an orange red glow argon
glows a pale lavender helium a dusty
pink Krypton a silver white and xenon a
light purple these five gases can be
combined with color-coded tubing to
create an electrified rainbow of text
and images business-owners soon realized
how effective these colorful beacons
were for attracting customers and unlike
a light bulb a neon sign has no
incandescent filaments to burn out and
can shine continuously for 40 years
before the gas depletes by the 1930s
neon signs were lighting up storefronts
all over the world because of the glass
tubes fragile nature it usually wasn't
feasible to ship them over long
distances instead most neon signs were
created by local neon shops and then
installed nearby signs with humor
personality and intricate designs
proliferated no two exactly alike but by
the end of World War two plastics had
become widely available in
spencer and plastic signs supplanted
neon as messengers of modernity many
towns removed the on signs they viewed
as old-fashioned today neon sign
production is only a fraction of what it
was at its peak
[Music]
but the craft of tube bending lives on
relatively unchanged new creations
handcrafted by local artisans join
survivors from the heyday of neon hiding
in plain sight in city streets around
the world
you